[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to lab Roots the life
of her mind an interview series devoted
to in learning how women think about
their research their field and their
future let's get started today we are in
conversation with Shiloh Nelson
professor of kinesiology at Pierce
College in Woodland Hills California
full disclosure Professor Nelson and I
are long time colleagues at Pierce and
I've long been an admirer of Professor
Nelson you are going to see why very
soon
um in addition to her academic work
Shiloh is a yoga instructor a certified
personal trainer and a competitive
bodybuilder previously she served in the
United States Air Force and was a
cheerleader for the Seattle Seahawks
while earning her master's degree from
California State University at
Northridge Nelson began began teaching
in csun's kinesiology Department in 2010
she began teaching at Pierce College
which was just down the road from
northridge's campus eventually she
became the chair of the Kinesiology
Department welcome Professor Nelson and
thank you for taking time to give us a
glimpse into the life of your mind well
thank you for having me I appreciate it
I don't know how much in my mind you
want to see but here we go oh let us
have it all
um all right so so if I've got my
chronology right uh you followed in your
parents footsteps uh by entering the
military service uh first
um subsequently you became a
professional cheerleader and then a
kinesiologist
um how did these seemingly diverse
Endeavors come about what brought you to
military service either in addition to
or apart from that that was what you
grew up with um by way of your your
parents
um how did you get to cheerleading kind
of how did you get to you yeah
um yes both my mother and father were
Air Force and so that's how they met and
then um so I grew up the first few years
of life in the military and then my my
father got out we moved to Washington
State so I'm a transplant from the east
coast to Pacific Northwest not a seven
and so I grew up there so I consider
that home and so upon getting ready to
graduate from high school
um my parents are like yeah I think the
military would be good for you you not
only make money for school but you'll
get to see the world you'll grow up a
little bit quicker and it'll help you I
think do better in school because you'll
learn a little bit of discipline and
you'll get a lot of benefits
you are a veteran and so
um I kind of kicked and screamed a
little bit but I ended up going into the
military uh I think it was the best
decision I could have ever made
Julie
um I enjoyed the people that I met I'm
still friends with a lot of people I
only did four years so I've been out for
an extremely long time but I'm still
friends with a lot of people that are um
that I met in the military so I made a
lot of lifelong friends I did grow up
really quickly and sometimes when I'm
interacting with our students that are
like 18 19 I'm like why can't you and
then I have to think back I was in the
military at that age there's a
difference between being in the military
1819 and going straight from home to
college so I have to kind of have to
catch myself with that sometimes but um
once I got out of the military I was
working at a department store and I was
going to college using my GI a little
and my I was working for Clinique and so
I was doing makeup and my my boss was
looked at me one day she said I think
you should be a Sea Gal which is what
the Seahawk cheerleaders were called at
the time and I was like what is that and
she's like for the Seattle Seahawks and
I laughed I was like they suck who
cheers for them because they were really
Dad in the 90s I'm like they actually
have people that cheer for them she's
like that's not the point the point is
you have discipline you're in the
military you know how to work hard
because you were in the military so you
do hard things and this can be a
challenge for you and something
completely out of your wheelhouse
because I never took a dance class in my
life prior to that
um and she's like Anna can open doors
for you you can meet a lot of really
good people that can help Propel you
forward and you'll make lifelong friends
so I you know I hoomed in hog kicked and
screamed and you know got my car drove
to Seattle and went through the tryouts
and I was one of six people to make it
I'm out of over 200 women so I was very
surprised so she's right I do do hard
things
and and I've made lifelong friends
um as she said because I just did one
season and after that then I um because
I took a year off from school and I knew
that I needed to finish school I put
stress on myself to finish school by a
certain time because by that time I was
25 and I was like oh my gosh my class
reunions in three years I cannot have
not have a college education by that
time and so I left Seattle and then
consequently I went to school and I got
my degree in kinesiology at Eastern
Washington University which is in Cheney
Washington right outside of Spokane in
Eastern Washington I did that's where I
did my undergrad and I found Fitness
while being in the military because
that's a part of military life staying
fit and I would go to the gym and I had
a roommate who had been a bodybuilder
and so I started working out with her
and that's how I learned to lift weights
and then I had an aerobics instructor
who had lost over 200 pounds and so I
would take her classes and she would
carry her picture around and she would
always share her story and I found that
just fascinating and I was like well
what books did you read like what did
you do how did you do this and so I
would go to the library I don't think
people do that anymore I had to go to
the library and I would check out the
books that she had read and I would read
the books and I would look at
um the credentials of the people who
wrote the books and I was like what is
this exercise science what is this
kinesiologist what is this what is what
are these long words I can't pronounce
essentially
um but she was always happy and I was
always happy when I left her exercise
class and so it was something that
planted a seed and then
um fast forward I got into teaching
aerobics personal training and then I'm
like well I want to be the person that
writes these books and teaches people
how to do this what is how do I do that
and hence getting out of the military
the first person I met when I went back
from Washington State I mean Amy and she
graduated from University of Idaho with
the degree in exercise science so I was
like that's what I'm looking for and she
said yes that's what you're looking for
she had been in the Army and so
um so she kind of helped me on my path
and then fast forward here I am
so you so you a couple of times both
major moments in your life the decision
to go into the military the decision to
try out for the for the Seahawks you
mentioned Kicking and Screaming what was
it that you
why the Kicking and Screaming what was
happening a tank you know people people
are afraid to change you're comfortable
you know I was comfortable at home I you
know I grew up in a good family in a
good neighborhood I had everything I
wanted why would I want to leave that to
go and be yelled at you know
well I could have my mother do that I
know her
well I'm not gonna have a total stranger
to that you know so that was part of it
the fear of change the fear of being
away from home
um fear of doing something hard
and
um but my parents were like you've done
hard things your whole life and you know
and you know they went through scenarios
of things that I had done and they're
like you you can you can do this and
it's just only gonna Propel you forward
and so that's what I claim to the fact
that it's going to propel me forward and
then when I um when Margaret my my boss
at the clean counter said you know try
out for Seahawks I'm like well I've
never taken a dance class I'm not a
model uh you know I don't have tall
rocket legs you know I'm only 5'4 you
know so all these things are like in my
in my head and she's like you know you
can do hard things you're just in the
military and you have the discipline and
the skill set she's like you know you
teach aerobics you have some sense of
Rhythm yeah you know how to count to
eight apparently and so you know she
said the worst case scenario is you
don't make it but you meet people and
you put yourself out there and you try
so you weren't afraid to fail because
it's not really failing you're learning
something so I'm like well that goes
back to what my parents said it's only
gonna Propel me forward and so I just
kind of relied on that and so then
that's when I went but it was just the
fear of change and you know I just
gotten out of the military at that time
and I thought I was doing good I was
going to school I'm using my GI Bill you
know doing what I thought I didn't think
there was anything else you know my
vision was kind of narrowed I didn't
think there was anything else for me to
do and she was like no no there's more
out there so scoot Scoot and so
and what what I one of the one of the
things that I think is really
interesting about what seems to be this
you know wildly diverse uh or Divergent
paths right military uh uh
uh not you know working at the makeup
counter but but while you're doing that
you were already
um studying uh Kinesiology if I'm not
mistaken and you were already you know
uh trained um uh as a at that point not
as a yoga instructor but you were you
were teaching aerobics and then physical
fitness right so it seems like
like the Seahawks would be really um a
Divergent path from what you did in the
military but you've made this really
interesting connection like they're both
grounded in
um discipline they're both grounded in
um you know physical strength and
control of your body and understanding
your body so I wonder like was was
understanding your body or was being
comfortable with with with fitness
exercise Sports whatever was that part
of your childhood
um no actually I did not play sports
growing up at all
um my mom was afraid of me getting hurt
and so I so I did not play sports and
then once I got into high school she was
like oh my God you have nothing to put
on your college application you need to
go do something and I'm like well I had
to learn how to play sports in junior
high there's no way I'm gonna even make
the JV team at this point you know
because she had you know she had no
concept of it and I think my dad I think
he said he wrestled in ninth grade then
that was it so so neither one of them
really understood the value of sports in
schools
um and all the the skills that you
learned that you don't learn in a
classroom necessarily and
um so then I just went and tried out for
the cheerleading squad in high school
and I was a high school cheerleader but
not the ESPN guy it was more like that
go
I know I think that pretty much anybody
can do if you know how to clap and you
know how to make a fist and do this you
could have bid on my spot
[Laughter]
okay so there is a little at least a
little bit of a connection between what
what became the the year the season of
Seahawks and and High School
so you are yeah the Seahawks and they
were they're really professional
cheerleaders are really dancers that's
what they are they are really dancers
and everybody had a dance background but
this one right here
um so it was it was a challenge I
started taking dance classes I paired up
with the best dancers on the squad and
it became another job for me I worked
part-time at the clinic counter in
Seattle I transferred from one mall to
another and then I had my practices with
the Seahawks and then I literally
probably put in another 20 30 hours on
my own I didn't know what a pot of beret
was I didn't know what inside outside
turn was I think it was a point my toes
when I kick like what is that we don't
do that in aerobics and so so it was it
was a completely different animal
completely different animal it's like if
you aren't a tennis player and you go
out there and you're like trying to
teach you how to play tennis and it's
just different mechanics and motor
skills that I wasn't used to so it was
definitely
um a challenge and in that way but you
know having at least teaching aerobics
and understanding the fundamentals of
movement at least that was helpful and
and making that that leap and it was a
big leap and my toes weren't pointed
so
all right so so
um obviously you know you've had a a
lengthy career
um outside of academic life
um you mentioned earlier that one of the
um
one item in in sort of developing your
uh your work in your major was sort of
seeing who was writing the books that
you were reading right
um how is that part of what sparked your
interest in going on to graduate school
specifically for kinesiology or
um was there some other motivation that
brought you to
to the classroom in your discipline
um for one is going to grad school I was
um living in Portland Oregon at that
time and so I was working for a fitness
chain and I was their group exercise
coordinator which simply met I ran the
aerobics program I hired I trained and
while doing that I also worked for a
national company
um when you're in the fitness industry
there's many different certifications to
have and there's different certifying
bodies and so I got hired by a company
the acronym is Alpha
AFAA which stood um stood for because
they've now since been bought out but uh
this is for the aerobic fitness
Association of America so they were one
of the certifying bodies so in Fitness
we have the American College of sports
medicine that would kind of be like the
Surgeon General in the medical field so
we have the American College of sports
medicine and then under that you
umbrella you have different certifying
companies and and so if you Mia had a
gym you'd want to be sure that your
trainers and instructors were certified
because it's a liability for you and so
I worked for one of those companies so I
got to travel the country certifying
people to work in in these facilities
and so I was doing that and running
um like three or four different gyms for
24-Hour Fitness at the time and
um I was like wow you know I
want to make more than 36 000 a year
I want to buy a house and
um I'm getting paid as much or less than
people who are trainers who don't even
have my same amount of Education
and but yet they're learning from me
because I'm the person that's teaching
these certifications that made no sense
to me and one of the go-to argue that
when it came to Promotions and you know
getting salary increases my education
didn't mean anything to them
and so like we can get someone like you
that's just certified and I'm like well
I'm gonna be the person that writes this
stuff how about that and so
um so I started looking around at um
graduate programs and then a friend of
mine is flipping me a job from Nike
because I lived right next to the Nike
campus in Beaverton
um which is like a suburb of Portland
and I would drive past the Nike campus
every day going to work
and so I was like hmm let me look at
this job and so I looked at the job and
the job required a masters in
kinesiology and it was working with
designing clothes and shoes for Nike so
he wanted someone with emphasis and
biomechanics which falls under the
umbrella of Kinesiology and so I'm like
well I'm gonna go and change careers in
and get out of this Fitness and I'm
gonna get my Master's I'm gonna come
back I'm gonna get hired at Nike and I'm
gonna work at Nike and I'm gonna make
double 36 000 a year and that's my goal
and so I'm off to graduate school I
can't
so the mere motivation of just being
insulted by not being paid my value yeah
I mean so so I've I've you're reminding
me that I think I've heard before that
the fitness industry is notoriously
um a low paying industry for the for the
you know for for employees for the
experts
um uh
do you have why do we know why is it I
mean
why is that I think with the fitness
Industries the gyms take a lot of the
big cut so many times when people don't
have experience like I'll tell people go
and work at a gym to make your mistakes
under somebody else's umbrella somebody
else's Insurance under somebody else's
liability make your mistakes
and then also also have people there
that you can learn from and you'll come
across a lot of different populations
because many times they just feed you
new members and so you have no idea whom
you're going to be working with and so
um learn there and then move on and work
for yourself because then you can make
more money and so that's what many
people do so they work privately I mean
I'm in La I mean these trainers are
charging a hundred hundred and fifty
dollars an hour and if you're a
celebrity trainer you're getting 200 an
hour you know to do the same thing that
the person at 24 Hour Fitness getting
25.
you know but now you're not sharing with
with the big box clubs you're actually
taking that money in for yourself and
doing whatever you're doing with it so I
think that's where it is because many of
these gyms know that once you become
really good you're not going to stay
there you're going to leave and many
times you take those people your clients
with you even though you're not supposed
to many times they come with you anyway
and that's and that's kind of how it
goes so they know they can get another
one just like you
so sort of a cultural and historical
um okay and then yeah I mean when you go
into the high-end clubs it's a little
bit better but it's still not the same
as if you work for yourself like I I
found that out when I I'm after graduate
school I worked for myself as a trainer
and I mean a lot more
and the the other with the the Striking
feature of of that period well sorry the
other striking feature of of that
problem is you mentioned that you you
had this education and and
certifications more so than let's say
somebody else working alongside you but
that didn't give you any
greater compensation so
um so so curiously enough and so many
um in a number of areas an academic life
people make less than they do in
corporate life right so they'll leave
academ it's almost like leaving the you
know service
um to make more money but in the case of
of
um Fitness and and exercise science it's
the other way around so and then you
mentioned again ah I'm going to write
the the books and the manuals and the
curriculum the curricula for these
um certifications
um what what intrigued you about that
process like why how did why do you
think that piqued your interest
repeatedly
um because I like to learn I always
laugh that if I could go to school for
someone and just let the information
transfer to them I would I'd be a career
student I was just actually having that
conversation with somebody last night so
I like to go to school like to learn I I
you know I'm just you know kind I don't
want to say I'm a nerd because it has
like a negative connotation but I mean
it in a loving way
and so
um I just like knowledge I love the
human body I think it's fascinating you
can make the body do anything like
literally anything with the right kind
of training and nutrition and rest you
can make the body do just really
magnificent things and so I I like to
read about about that and
um I also am a student of movement and
movement quality that's what keeps you
safe and
um and you see a lot of I like to watch
people walk I'm like one of those
strange people and I like to watch how
people sit and you know like this or you
know like this or like this you know I
like to look at body language and then
you should start to look at mechanics a
lot of times and then it becomes like a
little bit of a puzzle like I think that
they how they have shortness on the side
of tightness over here they have
weakness and this is why they're having
these kinds of shifts and
um I like to understand and study that
because that's really important to know
when you're working with somebody
one-on-one and so I having been like the
aerobics coordinator and training people
and working for Alpha and training
people and fitness and movement I was
always very meticulous about how you
approach movement and how you taught
movement to people because that's really
important to keep people safe and people
are sick then they continue and then
they see results and as they see more
positive results then they continue and
and and it just goes on then they become
happy then they become self-sufficient
and then they re you know so there's
just nothing but any everything that's
positive so
being somebody who can help like be an
educator in that field because that's
the basics of
um of exercises movement and motor
patterns that that to me was very
interesting I really felt like I was
very good at really kind of educating
and
teaching and parlaying that information
to people to be successful when I work
with my clients and when I teach classes
and I like seeing a light bulb go off
and so I'm like well you got to write
the material and write it really well in
order to actually teach that material in
order for people to take it and move on
so I always felt like it was a
responsibility since I have the book
knowledge to be the person to kind of
help facilitate that if I answered your
question yeah oh yeah yes yes and it
actually leads um beautifully
um into
um how you so I know you you started
while you were in grad school you were
um a grad instructor
um but that so that but how did you end
up um going down the road to to pierce
and then you know fast forward your
chair of the department your if I'm not
mistaken effectively I don't know if I
want to say rebuilding you'll share with
us kind of what how that happened but
um or or what was involved but how did
it happen that you landed at Pierce and
then
um became chair and um sort of rebuilt
the program
okay so let me give you the polite
version of how I became chair
um
assistant going out there uh in The
Ether so
but no um as a grad assistant
um at CSUN and I was also a great
assistant when I was an undergrad too
which is very interesting because what I
had found out
because when you study Kinesiology you
don't learn to be a personal trainer or
an aerobics instructor like you don't
take classes in that you go out and you
learn that on your own and so it's not a
part of the curriculum and part of
curriculum is your Chemistry your math
your physics your Kinesiology your
biomechanics your physiology your
Anatomy
that's the core meat of it and then some
movement type activity classes and then
pedagogy and so that's the meat and
potatoes of the degree and so if you
want to go into fitness you have to go
and get that information on your own and
usually people come to this field
because they were athletes with the
exception of mwah
and and so they want to go back and
coach and do these things and stuff they
go out they get a degree in kinesiology
and then they go out and get these
additional trainings
and so
um what I found is that none of my
professors
were proficient or had the knowledge of
how to teach movement classes oh yeah so
I was like what do you mean you don't
know how to teach aerobics what do you
mean I'm not a personal train they knew
their subject they knew the physiology
it took a lot of cardiac rehab class
classes at Eastern so you know she could
teach me how to read an EKG but she
could not teach me how to make my legs
stronger you know and so she might have
understood the fundamentals of it but
putting it into action was completely
different and so that was how I got my
jobs because I was actually doing that
first before coming to the university I
was already in the field and so they
were like oh you have the skill so when
I was in undergrad they're like yeah
you're greeting them I mean you're
giving them grades but don't tell them
that you are a pair of them and I was
like okay and so here I am grading my
years
um but because the the professors didn't
know how to teach these classes I ended
up with it that's how I got my and my
graduate teaching our graduate
assistantship at CSUN same thing they're
like oh you're already in our office
instructor and personal trainer oh
you're already certified all right so I
didn't get the exercise science labs or
to buy mechanic Labs at grad
assistance.i got all the activity
classes because that's what that's
that's what they needed you know
somebody who was actually doing those
things and so that ended up getting me
the job I first started in the district
at Mission College yeah I did too
because yeah because I got a phone call
from this lady I later got to know her
as um Cindy Cooper but at the time I
just got this person on the phone that
was just like are you Shiloh I'm all
yeah you called me
and she and she said yeah I got your
name from so and so on so and so
um do you have your Masters I was like
yeah I just you know I just graduated
and she's like okay you are a trained
aerobics instructor oh yeah I'm
certified such and such and I work for
them great
can you start next week
I had no idea what that meant I had no
idea who I was talking to but she's like
I need you to show up here and so I
drove out to the campus and I met her
and she was very nice and they sat me
down and they maybe do all the paperwork
that the district has and then and
then gave me some keys and said start
teaching and I was just like
um okay you know I mean luckily I I
don't know I'm good at what I do because
that's how I stumbled into all my jobs
and that from there parlayed into
working at more Park College because
they needed someone to teach math
Pilates and because they didn't have
people who actually did it in the field
they had people with master's degrees
but not people who actually had the
actual application part of the
activities that they were looking for
the fitness ones they had a lot of
people who have played basketball soccer
baseball they had a lot of those people
teach those classes but the fitness
classes are just a different animal on
their own and so that's what got me in
so when there was that opening for
Pierce because I was actually working
full-time downtown for the Army Corps of
Engineers I was their Wellness
coordinator so I was working for the
government and still teaching as adjunct
that mission I applied and there was
over 100 Apple applicants that apply
and I was remember I was at a meeting at
Kinesiology meeting and everybody was
talking about they were applying for
this job at Pierce and a lot of them had
phds and and Kinesiology in their little
areas and stuff and I was like why am I
even gonna bother like applying for this
job and I'm not getting a job over a PhD
person and somebody who's already been
in you know teaching at other campuses
and some a lot of them were full-timers
already in the district in kinesiology
but I applied anyway and in my interview
the job description was written you know
the the qualifications and that you have
to have in the district for the
discipline of Kinesiology with an
emphasis and they rattled off all these
Fitness things they didn't say like
basketball or anything like that so
aerobics and yoga yoga was the big thing
and I was a trained Yoda teacher and
that I see
enforcement personality
um I landed me the job and so Fitness
and being proficient in that has all I
believe was the biggest part of why I'm
even here today in the district and and
landed me all these jobs at the colleges
because I I'm an anomaly many people
have the bulk knowledge
but they don't know how to do the
application you say what's 32 count
phrasing they'll they'll you'll get the
deer in the headlights you know if you
say how do you choreograph a step class
you get deer in the headlights you know
and then how do you do that for multiple
skill levels and keep everybody looking
the same
at the same time and keeping everybody
in time I mean that's a whole different
skill set that you don't learn in the
classroom
well and it sounds so so I don't know
the proper terminology so I'm gonna it
sounds either like
you've you've Blended
to disciplines I know you talked about
you know skill sets right
um either you Blended two disciplines or
what you do is applied Kinesiology so
you understand you know the the
theoretical and and scientific
you practice how that plays out in
actual movement whether it's yoga or
aerobics or something
um similar yeah exactly I mean when I
used to when I was going through my
undergraduate I was personal training as
well and I could study for my test while
training my clients I'm like okay bring
your elbows in you're gonna do a little
elbow flexion you're Contracting the
long and short head of the bicep and
they just thought I was so smart but I
was really studying
yeah I was just regurgitating my notes
while I was training them and and so you
know but I was what was really neat I
mean again I can't speak about other
disciplines other than maybe a foreign
language discipline we're actually using
the language like if you go and live
abroad and you use the language in a
natural setting you're able to take that
skill set and apply it in the classroom
okay here is the grammatical way of
writing and seeing these words but this
is really how it's done conversationally
and this is what you really sound like
don't sound like the textbook when you
go to France because they're going to
look at you all weird
down like this yeah because you had the
experience of maybe studying abroad in
France and being in the culture and so
it's kind of the the same thing with um
the Kinesiology so it's a little
disheartening sometimes when I go to
meetings on on on any campus really and
enter and interact with different
disciplines they really just think
you're kicking a ball and catching a
ball and that's all that's all you're
really doing it's like you know Nursery
School play time is kind of how they
look at you and it's like no no I don't
think you can do it I do you teaching
the people auditory Visual and
kinesthetically all at the same time
Crossing language barriers
um skill sets I mean I remember I asked
a woman to bend her elbow and she moved
her foot and was like
so I had to go and drain her hand and go
like this oh I wasn't doing anything
vulgar but you know what I mean that was
us I just realized
no no but it works it worked you played
it beautiful but you know I mean because
a lot of times people don't even have
that connection with themselves and how
that works and so when you have to like
teach that and keep people moving and
have them have a good time and make it
accessible and make the exercise fun
as well as movement achievable I mean
it's it's a completely different animal
so yeah it is blending it's blending all
the knowledge and skill set and then
applying it to that body in front of you
and sometimes that knowledge and skill
set and that book book smart goes out
the window and you have to adapt to that
that body that's in front of you and
figure it all out not just physically
but just and mentally and emotionally
too so all that comes into play too and
then when you have like I used to have a
kickboxing class I had like 70 plus
people in it and you know it keeps 70
people moving in time and keeping them
happy and keeping and managing that and
having that control you know it's a
different skill set and because it's so
so yeah it's it's incredibly
individualized but you're doing it in a
group and then that leads me to you know
my next question it's almost like we
practice this because you just
um
um I do have one follow-up but I don't
want to to break that that flow so I'll
try to remember to come back to it but
right so so you're talking about having
this sort of cohesive group
while you're doing this sort of
individual work right
and then March 2020 hits right and we
all you know go where we are right now
which is you know in the in the zoom
meeting and
um
you know so so one of the the
when I was thinking about
um you know my own discipline in
relation to a discipline that requires
the
a lot of complicated
um movements and learning how to hold
positions it just you know whether it's
yoga or anything else thinking oh my
gosh how are you know people in dance or
Kinesiology
um uh how are they doing this so how did
you make the transition and apparently
do it so seamlessly because I I came
across a video where you know you it was
like it was like May of 2020 or earlier
and you were like come on we're doing
this everything's you know we're going
to do this together it's going to be
great and I wasn't surprised because it
was you but at the same time I'm
thinking you know there were so many
people who made who had such a hard time
to transitioning
how did you think about and then execute
making your classes your Kinesiology
classes work
in this online environment I think it
helped me make it better
huh actually
um I used a lot of my work that was on
Zoom or online I should say even now
that I'm back to my face-to-face classes
um so when it initially happened it was
like
and um okay I gotta film myself but I
can't I can't get myself all these
different angles you know I I I I don't
have a husband and my neither one of my
dogs know how to hold a phone and so
inhale and the cat's no good either and
so I'm like who's going to get me all
these different angles and so I spent a
lot of time finding videos online that
had movements in different angles and it
was still somebody doing doing it you
know
the regular way and then right next to
them in a little box in insert would be
a modified version of that exercise kind
of how I would teach it in class you
know and so and I'd have the students
film themselves and I would give them
feedback but I'm like
I have to give them more so I was
lecturing more and filming them or I was
Finding additional like TED talks and
things to kind of give an emphasis to
what I was talking about and then
writing lots of questions or giving them
like articles to read and giving me some
reason more writing work that I didn't
necessarily do before and
um that kept their interest in my yoga
classes I really delved deep into the
philosophies of yoga which the writing I
was getting back from students like how
they were going through being depressed
and you know feeling just hopeless that
writing is very helpful for them it was
almost therapeutic it was like
journaling and that's kind of what they
would say to me and so I found that that
actually
kept them coming back and kept them
interested was the actual not just
discussions with each other and with me
but the um actual additional work that I
was giving them that I didn't
necessarily do in person
to that depth and so it it kept them
more engaged and they were actually
learning more about the human body they
were learning more about nutrition they
were learning more about how to take
care of themselves when it was like the
fitness-based classes and then filming
themselves and actually getting feedback
because they would actually have to make
like some of the corrections in the
movement so then you know when you're
teaching to a group of people in front
of you and you have on a headset and you
make you know you say X Y and Z you
shouldn't be shoulders back and down and
your arms up when you're teaching a
kickboxing class well nobody thinks
you're talking to them so they're just
doing this but when I get your video and
you're down here doing that and I'm like
we give you feedback and then it's very
specific and so then for you have to
make that correction so it kind of I
think help people in their Fitness
aspect uh as far as like with the yoga
classes
um it helped them a lot of students I
felt more emotionally because because of
the philosophy writings and learning
like the limbs of yoga and really kind
of dive deep into how you treat yourself
how you treat others how you interact
when you start talking about
um the eight limbs and you break it down
to the yamas and the niyamas and how you
interact with the world how you interact
with yourself and giving them additional
readings and and and prompts to write
out it really helped a lot of them and
so it helped me to keep those students
that um were brave enough to go on that
journey of being in a virtual
environment and so now I've kept a lot
of that now that I'm back face to face
and the the feedback I get now is that
they enjoy the more online stuff that
I'm doing than the actual practical
class itself
so that's why I say it actually made me
better because it forced me to actually
die that much deeper not just into the
subject matter which of course keeps me
more up to date because I had to find
up-to-date things because I'm no longer
teaching the certifications out there
um anymore but then it kept me just more
in tune with myself too and how I was
feeling during this time as well so
one and
um
am I right to think that
um one of the the the good things about
coming back to campus uh is goat yoga uh
or is that something I mean do do you do
we do that again or no and to anybody
not from Los Angeles and not having ever
been on the Pierce campus
um can you explain
how goat yoga came about what it is and
how it came about
goat yoga was started by a lady named
Laney was it morsel Morales something
like that up in Oregon and she was doing
like birthday parties on her Farm
and people and so you know she had
animals and everything and so people
were like oh this is you know this is
really great you know and and this yoga
teacher came to her and said how about I
you know teach a yoga class here on your
farm and so she did and she taught and
they were like little baby goats walking
around and so the lady Laney filmed it
sent it into her local like Farm
newspaper and then it just blew up from
there so that's where it actually
originated from and so people think it's
this magical thing of doing goat yoga
there's here in Los Angeles there's
puppy yoga there's cat yoga and so
there's all these different things so
what you're basically doing is you're
teaching yoga because at Pierce College
you know we have their our farm and so
we have goats and so I taught a yoga
class because they called me and or sent
me an email and it was during the week
of finals and so they wanted to do
something for the students to kind of
help calm them down during final examly
and they said would you you know you
teach yoga here would you come and do
goat yoga so I'm like great so the first
time I did it was a nice sunny day and
the little baby goats were walking
around they trying to eat your hair they
try and eat your clothes they eat
everything apparently
so instead of a lawnmower get yourself a
goat
um and so
that's how it started happening but what
I noticed is that they poo Non-Stop
luckily I didn't get any food on my
Madden step into it but then I was kind
of like hmm nobody talked about the
sanitariness of this
and so but it was really nice and the
whole premise of it is that it's not
only outside and and puts you in touch
with nature but animals have a very
calming and therapeutic effect so not
only do you have yoga itself but then
you add in animals and being outdoors in
nature so it kind of helps with anxiety
helps with stress you know you're kind
of boosting your immune system because
you're you know you're decreasing
cortisol because you're decreasing
stress and you're you know you're
bringing in those happy endorphins who
doesn't like cute baby animals I mean
unless you're just a crazy weird person
you know who doesn't like baby animals
and so
um so it has that effect to it that
makes people gravitate towards it but
they do poo a lot so you know go ahead
and try it but don't worry your best
shoes don't worry you're good don't wear
your church shoes
[Laughter]
your approach to the story you told
about
um moving from being in the same
physical space with um people uh with
your class members to being in the in
the virtual environment
um how you adapted and then and then the
the story you tell about about goat yoga
it was just reveals that you're I mean
your Game right you're like what you
know what is something that I can do to
make what I'm doing better for the
people who are involved
um and that's just I think such a you
know like a testament to the quality of
your of your character
um because you can you well you're
genuinely in this for
the the ways that it can benefit all
aspects you know of our of our lives and
it and it also
um reminds me of
um
this this other question that I wanted
to ask you about
um kind of who is kinesiology for like
what I'm hearing from you is that
um it's
it yes from the from the standpoint of
of
um the fitness side of things we have
you know current or former athletes and
then you know from the academic side of
things you know we have the the the if
you will the more the the cyan C types
right but that Kinesiology is really a
great way to to blend
um both the
um the theoretical scientific and the
the the Practical and so it seems like
you know it's it's for for anybody for
example someone I was working with is is
thinking about uh becoming a
chiropractor and I said oh well have you
taken any of Professor Nelson's
Kinesiology classes you know I don't
know about Kinesiology but my suspicion
is that yes you're going to learn
everything from you know Anatomy to
motion and right it's the root of the
word right
um so all of this to to say
um kind of what is
your advice to someone who is kind of
lurking around the you know but not in
um Kinesiology who who should
you should get involved in that
discipline we want everybody because we
want people in our classes oh I'm sorry
I I digress
[Laughter]
yeah yeah there's that little small
heart
um well we at the community college the
way and that's like a whole different
story of how the two-year degree was
written you get the introduction to
Kinesiology from us and it breaks the
discipline down into the philosophy of
Kinesiology to the sociological aspects
of it to the psychological aspects of it
because psychology sociology philosophy
all that falls into it because you know
we had to take I had to teach them well
forget the name of it was a sociological
aspect of Kinesiology it was some class
I had to take like that
um in grad school you know so it was
taught by a Kinesiology Professor with
an infinite cyst on sociology and just
how you know how the discipline works
you know within social groups and things
like that and so
um so it it does it dives into many
different disciplines
um Kinesiology does and when you're like
looking at people wanting to get into it
I tell students who they think I like to
exercise so I don't want to study
Kinesiology I'm like we better like math
and science I'm not good at math you're
not going to do well in these classes
because in your biomechanics class
you're gonna have to know you're gonna
have to have that math through like trig
and stuff you're gonna have to learn how
to figure out you know if you hit the
ball here which way is it gonna go and
how fast is it going to go I mean you
need you need to know how to do that you
know I don't know people use calculators
anymore but I had the big scientific one
that you could bicep curl the little
heavy ones you know second function you
know you have to put that in and so
um and then I tell them you have to take
Anatomy classes you're working with the
human body you know what what is this
what is it attached to what's the joint
action all right so I was listening to a
trainer talk yesterday at a workshop or
he was trying to explain the um strength
and where you're stronger you're
stronger here than yours than being
there and you know that's basically
lever links right so you're talking a
little bit
um and that's you know about
biomechanics which is getting math and a
little bit of physics and so people need
to have that understanding that that's
what the discipline is and then you have
to take the physiology classes which
means you have to have had chemistry
because now you start talking about
metabolism and what the carbs do what
the fats do what does protein do how do
you fuel the energy system so if you're
writing a program for an athlete what
position does that athlete play is that
so are they using an anaerobic system
are they using an aerobic system based
on the sport now how do you write their
strength training program how do you
write their program for when they're in
season versus when they're coming into
season versus when they're kind of going
out of season and so there's all these
different things that people don't think
about when it comes to to to Kinesiology
so I'm like I'm glad that you like to
exercise I'm glad that you grew up
playing 10 different sports throughout
your entire life but
you can't take you and put you on
somebody else you've got to understand
the discipline the math the science yes
I had to take English classes I had to
learn how to write I had to write a
program to give to somebody
um but I also have to know how to adapt
things to that individual person and
sometimes you gotta scrap everything
that you learn and then figure it out at
least you have the basic knowledge
and figure it out with that body in
front of you and many times it's the
emotions that you're dealing with with
people then really the physical that
you're dealing with with people and
you're dealing a little bit with their
psyche then more so than dealing with
their body so anybody who wants to come
into this field has got to have that
understanding it's a lot more than
teaching them what you know how to do
you really need to teach them what they
want to do but keeping in the back of
your head okay there are certain things
in order for you to get there that I
know you need to do so now I gotta tear
what you need to do into what you want
to do so you think you're getting what
you want but really I want you to have
so like when I get a female client who
just wants to work her legs and doesn't
want to do her upper body at all because
she doesn't want to look like a man and
I'm like you don't make enough
testosterone I can't believe people
still think that in 2023 but like so
unless you're on the juice it's not
gonna happen and so and you can eat and
lift and and curl a house it's not gonna
happen and so
um I'm like okay great you want to work
your legs I'll give you dumbbells
because you need to have additional
weights for your legs but then I'll have
a lunge with the dumbbell curl and a
shoulder press like I'll sneak that in
but to say you're sneaky yeah I'll have
her do step UPS in a trunk rotation with
a medicine ball you know so I'm getting
that upper body or overhead shoulder
press like I'm so I'm getting the upper
body in there but her focus is oh I'm
doing my legs so I'm giving her what she
wants but I'm also giving her what she
needs but I have to know how to how to
do that and put that in there without it
without it being so obvious or going or
it's about my agenda you know going
going in there and people need to really
have that understanding it's not really
the physical
so much as it is dealing with an actual
human being and then also knowing that
yeah you're I got a few tests with some
D's you know because it's very hard that
that math and that and and doing those
long we call them was it wall problems
in chemistry where you had to have to
convert things and and to get to the end
problem because and then having to redo
those tests and going to office hours
because I really had to have an
understanding because I'm going to be
working with a human being and I and
I've had students who've thought about
Kinesiology and then I see them years
later and they change their major they
went to sports management
because they could they realized they
couldn't do the math classes you know or
they realized they don't like science
that much and so I would tell people you
gotta like math and science make friends
with it but you also have to know how to
interact really really well with human
beings in order to be successful in this
kind here did I answer answer questions
and you have been very successful in
this career so
we'll try what so that I try oh no you
do you do
um Professor Shiloh Nelson thank you so
much for taking time uh out of your busy
schedule I don't know how you find time
to do everything you do but take it on
from your schedule to share a little bit
of the life of your mind with us
um I appreciate you and thank you for
all that you do and I hope that we'll be
able to to chat again soon and maybe
we'll
um do some you tell us a little bit
about how bodybuilding has fit into all
of this oh yeah that too
the roommate in the military that was
the bodybuilder that's kind of where it
started
well thank you thank you so very much I
appreciate you and um I hope that I get
to see you sometime soon okay sounds
awesome thank you for having me I
appreciate you asking me thank you